字幕: Toshiro Suzuki
校正: Koichiro YODA
僕は 小さい頃ですね
映画『スターウォーズ』が
大好きだったんですが その理由は
映画『スターウォーズ』というのは
高い才能を持つことよりも
その才能の使い方を
高い次元で理解すること
その方が人生にとっては
重要だということを
伝えてくれているからだと
思っています
映画スターウォーズの中には
ダースヴェーダーと呼ばれる
キャラクターが出てきます
彼は 天才中の天才でした
世の中を変えると思われていた
だけど 自らの根底に流れる
愛の存在に気付けず
ダークサイドに落ちてしまった
一方で その息子である
ルーク・スカイウォーカーというのは
彼よりは才能がなかった
だけど自分の才能の使い方を
正しく理解していたため
最終的にダースヴェーダーを
倒すことができた
つまり この映画というのは 実は
高い才能を持つことよりも
その才能の使い方を
高い次元で理解していること
その方が私たちの人生にとって
もっとプラスになると
そういうことを伝えてくれているのだと
僕は認識しています
そして その差を分けたのは
自分の根底に流れる愛情や深い感情に
気付けるかどうかだったと
僕は ある時
人間には３つの才能があるのではないか
という仮説を持ちました
そして それを本にしました
そして それは ベストセラーになりました
その３つというのは
１つは創造性
独創的で 見たこともないプロセスで
物事を進める才能
２つは再現性
論理的で堅実なプロセスで
物事を進める才能
３つは共感性
人の気持ちや感情に配慮しながら
物事を進める才能
みなさんは この３つのうち
どれが自分の才能として
強いと思われますか？
だけど 僕が思うのは
自分が何の才能を持っているかよりも
はるかにもっと重要なのは
その才能を何のために使うのか？
それだ と 今 僕は確信しています
そして 実は きっかけとなるのは
愛情 あるいは深い感情に
自らの根底に流れるその気持ちに
気付くことだというふうに
確信しています
僕は 小さい頃 体が弱くて
喘息で そしてアトピーもありました
だから 学校に行きたくても
行けない日もありました
悔しい思いも たくさんしました
だけど その時でも 振り返ってみると
自分の父親や あるいは母親 家族は
無償の愛で自分をサポートしてくれて
そして育ててくれた
だから 今になって思うのは
その彼らにその恩を返すのは前提で
それよりも少しだけ大きな輪で返すこと
それが自分の才能の
使い方であるというふうに確信しています
そして どれだけ大きな輪で
返せるのかどうか
それが自分の才能の大きさによって
規定されている
こういう構造だというふうに
認識しています
つまり 重要なのは
自分の才能を
正しく理解するということは
自分の根底の中に流れている
愛情や深い感情に気付くこと
それがいつもスタートだということです
みなさんも不思議に
思ったことはないですか？
なぜ アーティストや
ミュージシャンというのは
歳をとればとるほど
年齢を重ねれば重ねるほど
いきなり 世界平和や
愛について歌い出すか
いきなり歌い出しますよね？
僕もすごい ちっちゃい頃は
不思議で仕方ありませんでした
だけど 今になって理解したのは
それは そのタイミング その年齢が
そのアーティストやミュージシャンが
「自分の根底の中に
こんな感情があったんだ」と
確信を持ったタイミングだと
そういうことだというふうに
認識しています
人は死を意識すると
自分の人生観や考え方が
変わるというふうに言われています
僕は 実はそれは
愛に気付くことの作用と
同じだというふうに今は認識しています
そして そのタイミングは
人によって遅かったり早かったりもする
遅い人は 死ぬ前日まで
世の中を憎み そして妬み
死ぬ前日まで
その感情があることに気付かない
だけど 早い人は
10代や20代で気付くかもしれない
また ある人は
自分の身近な人の死によって気付き
自分にこんな感情があったんだなと
気付くかもしれない
また ある人は
初めて自分の子供を見て
その顔を見た時に
自分の中にもこんな感情が
あったんだなというふうに
気付くかもしれない
つまり 大事なのは
自分の中に流れている
その根底に流れている愛情に
いつ 何歳で気付くのかだと
そして 先ほど死と同じと言いましたが
死も同じです
なぜ 死を意識すると
人の生き方は変わるのか
それは 自分の人生というのが
絶対的なものではなく
相対的なものであるというふうに
気付くからです
つまり 死 そして 愛
そして 才能というのは
実は 三位一体で
すごく身近なものなのです
近くにあるものなのです
死に気付くこと 愛に気付くこと
それは ほぼニアリーイコールで
自分の才能の使い方に気付くこと
自分のミッションに気付くことだと
僕は確信しています
今日は 実はこれで終わろうかなと
思っていたのですが
せっかくですね 神戸に帰って来たので
じゃあ 具体的に
僕が普段ですね 意識している —
才能というか能力の使い方みたいなのを
３つほどご紹介できればなというふうに
思っています
創造性の
最も尊い才能の使い方というのは
人とは違った形の
人間の在り方を認め 描くこと
僕はそう思っています
作家の役割 本質的な役割というのは
人とは違った形の愛を描き
そして それを丁寧に見せていくことです
みんなは Ａと言うけれど
だけど そのＡのそばにあるＡ’や
Ｂという あり方が
あってもいいんじゃないかと
それを描くことです
だから もしも今日
僕たちにできることがあるとすれば
家に帰って30秒や１分でもいいので
自分とは違うなとか 自分とは
全然考え方が違うなという人のために
その時間を使ってあげることだと
思っています
２つ目 再現性
再現性の
最も尊い使い方の１つというのは
背景を伝えることです
世の中にあふれている
映画やドラマというのは
実は 結論は全部一緒です
全部一緒
全部 愛は大事だ
愛は大事だ 愛は大事だ
希望は大事だ
希望は大事だ 希望は大事だ
よくよく考えてみたら全部一緒です
だけど 作家は
それを物語という技術を使って
丁寧に丁寧に描いていく
そして 物語を創るというのは
本当にとてつもなく大変な作業です
だから その対象に対して愛がなければ
描くことはできません
つまり もしも今日
僕たちができることがあるとすれば
家に帰って
たとえば 勉強しろとか
Ａをしろ Ｂをしろ と
その結論だけを言うのではなくて
その背景にある
なぜ それが大事なのか
なぜ それがあなたの人生にとって
重要なものであるのかというのを
その物語を描くことです
これが２つ目です
３つ目 共感性の
最も尊い才能の使い方というのは
実は 僕は
ご機嫌であることだと思っています
人は 偉くなればなるほど
リーダーになればなるほど
親になればなるほど
実は ご機嫌であることが
最も尊い才能の使い方だと確信しています
僕は 普段 IT企業の
経営者としても働いていますが
みなさんも想像して欲しいんですが
会社の上司やリーダーが
不機嫌だったり 怒っていたりしたら
それだけで才能が萎れてしまいますよね
で あるいは もっと言うのであれば
思い出して欲しいんです
みなさんが小学生や
幼稚園生だったとき
家に帰ってお父さんやお母さんが
イライラしていたり不機嫌だったら
それだけで心がシュンって
なりましたよね？
つまり 人は 偉くなればなるほど
リーダーになればなるほど
実は ご機嫌であることが
最も尊い才能の使い方の１つだと
僕は確信しています
冒頭に戻ります
映画『スターウォーズ』は
僕たちにこう問いかけていました
高い才能を持つことよりも
その才能の使い方を
高い次元で理解することの方が
はるかに重要ではないですかと
今日のお話がみなさんにとって
何かのフックになればとても幸いです
ありがとうございました
（拍手）